ibram x kendi um anti-racist expert
got himself into some hot water with the
woke crowd
uh that's his crowd because of some
comments he made about gender
recently this was during um starting
some sort of zoom
[Music]
meeting or seminar that he was involved
in now you you all know i've talked
about before that the victim hierarchy
and how that works on the left and even
rex candy
you know his position on that hierarchy
that that gives him the freedom to say a
lot of things but it does not give him
the freedom to speak freely about gender
the way the hierarchy works so he's not
at the top of the hierarchy and that's
how he got in trouble
for saying this obviously talking about
race even
talking about gender you know i think it
was last week
my daughter came home and said she
wanted to be a boy
you know which was horrifying uh for
my wife to hear myself to hear and so of
course
you know we're like okay what
affirmative messages about girlhood
you know can we be teaching her to
protect her
from whatever she's hearing in our home
or even outside of our home
that would make her want to be a boy um
and i suspect it's the same thing with
you know kids of color in which they're
regularly hearing these messages that
maybe
may want them to want to be white um or
even white children who are like i'm
happy i'm white
right you know what affirmative messages
are are we teaching them to to break
down those ideas
now the thing is almost everything he
said there was
correct except for the last part at the
end it's i if i i didn't quite
understand what he meant at the end it
sounded like he was saying
that it's a problem for a white child
who's happy to be white
um taking that aside
everything else he said you know if your
daughter comes home and says she wants
to be a boy
yeah that that is horrifying
that is horrifying because number one
this is your child
saying that she doesn't want to be who
she is
she's not happy with who she is at such
a fundamental level
as a parent of course that's a problem
and that's what he's he's touching on
here it's
a very good point it's a point that i've
made many of us have made many many
times
that if your child we hear so much about
well
we have to help kids accept themselves
for who they are and
be themselves all these things and yeah
you're right
but if a boy is saying that he's a girl
telling him that yeah you're a girl that
is not ex
helping him accept himself that is
helping him reject himself
so the the problem that he has is that
he's not
happy with who he is or he doesn't fully
understand
who he is especially if we're talking
about a kid who's like four years old
saying
a boy you're saying i'm a girl. this is
a child who just doesn't doesn't
understand there's nobody's talking
about
doesn't doesn't really know anything
about the world and very little about
himself and his own identity um so he's
confused
as you get older a child comes home from
public schools and middle school or high
school is saying this
well this is someone who's this is a
child who's who's dealing with
with something dealing with despair
dealing with um
confusion dealing with you know
self-loathing all of these things
and if you really love them and care
about them as a parent
then what you're going to do is help
them to accept who they are
your daughter comes home and says i wish
i was a boy
what's the correct message from a loving
parent
the correct message is no you're a girl
that's a beautiful thing that's a
wonderful thing
it's wonderful to be a girl that's the
message
but of course not allowed to say that
even ibra mex kendy isn't allowed to say
that
and he has participated in making this
woke brainwashed culture where those
kinds of very common sense
and important insights are not allowed
to be uttered
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content